Hello Freak bitches are you,
here are so many stories about China.
We talked about so many other things besides the stories about China,
which is why we have to keep going.
So you were about to tell some crazy noodle story.
Oh yeah.
So they had these street meat,
which is great.
And this is Shanghai that I knocked into this table.
I was like,
sounds like a fucking truck.
Fell over outside.
Uh,
yeah,
Shanghai.
But uh,
they were like,
be careful.
The meets great.
You just,
there's kebabs.
You pick it up,
they roast it,
give it back to you.
Point three,
two,
whatever it is.
Um,
but how much money you can get by with gesturing.
I learned hello and thank you.
Those are the only words I really knew.
Huh?
[inaudible] should I shouldn't,
I know that Ni Hao Kailand to show my kids watch.
Really?
Kylene
yeah,
that's cool.
That's crazy.
I can learn stuff.
Yeah.
So that's,
we say Shisha Shisha is like,
thank you.
Ah,
okay.
It's also used some other way,
but I don't know.
So how do you,
um,
gesturing,
I got sick at gesturing really except a couple of times I would like big about
to go into like a noodle store or something like that,
like a shop and I'd have to call my friend.
They gave you burner phones,
which was nice.
I could use and I was like,
hey,
how do you say noodles and how do you say beef?
They'll tell me both words and we just go in.
I'd be like,
what was it?
I forget now man.
Man,
man is noodles
and uh,
one of the guys from the Matrix movie is the word for beef.
Who's the black guy from the Matrix?
Morpheus.
No.
Okay.
What's the main guy from the close?
His name?
Neil.
Yeah.
That's how you say beef neo
and was the other one was the noodles man.
Again,
same yen,
yell or neo.
I don't know,
but I said that and then they're like,
they pointed the fucking menu.
Like there's the 18 things.
I'm like,
lady,
come on,
you can see me struggling with,
if I'm foreign and I come in and go beef noodle,
just pick something for him.
Listen to him just saying something.
Listen to his anus.
The amazing racist where if you would be like learn the language you fuck
was a parody sketches.
Sure.
Yeah of course.
It doesn't really feel that way ladies and gentlemen.
The comments on those are the best parts of it.
Got So angry you for those comments with the yeah.
Ooh Man.
Argue back and forth.
It still goes angry,
angry fuck heads.
So the noodles,
so they have these noodles is treat noodles.
You can get,
I was advised the first day like you don't want those why show me this video
that I can send you right now.
You can put up,
but they are here.
Put your,
put your email here and then just said it to me.
You can just send it to yourself.
But,
uh,
so the get the oil,
what they would do is they would go to the sewer,
they would take raw sewage out of the sewer and then boil it down.
The way they'd make wax hash wax,
they'd boil off the sewage and whatever was left.
That's cooking oil that they would use.
It's super fucking harmful.
And then sell to like a lot of the street noodle guys.
Yeah.
That face is what I made that same face.
They were cooking with sewer oil,
Bro.
It was going around.
So it's not common,
but it was possible.
So it's not like that's the only way they do it.
No,
but the street places where like you run a risk here,
it's cheaper oil.
All mine.
There's guns on that source.
Oh my God.
What does this China's food production of cost gimme some gutter oil making of
gutter oil.
Give me some volume.
Jamie.
Jesus Christ.
It's all in a day's work for this woman.
She opens up a manhole cover and scoops out as much slop as she can.
Delighted by what she finds,
what's how others might view as revolting.
She sees as a bonanza,
works in the streets at the southern Chinese city of Shenzhen,
a foot soldier in China,
so called Gutter oil industry.
I seriously almost through I just gagged.
She says she's made enough money to build a house for her family back in her
home.
Village miles to the north.
People are just awful.
She's scooping out to up.
Eventually winds up in a processing plant like this one where it's combined with
other animal fat.
Refuse to create recycled cooking.
Oil Work has put the oil in barrels for delivery to restaurants and to ordain.
How can you eat this?
If you eat it,
it can kill you.
Cooking oil has long been a cherish commodity in China.
What's the frying in a walk is the mainstay of daily meal preparation.
The high profit margins from gutter oil production of Provan irresistible
Chinese experts estimate that one 10th of China's cooking law is gutter oil,
which has been found to contain carcinogens.
Tell the toxins harmful for humans.
You think shit,
water is bad for you.
Breaking news and among street food vendors.
Production sites are often discovered after people living nearby.
Notice a nauseating stench and alert your shirt.
Really cooking your food.
Police have arrested scores of people across the country in recent years for
engaging in the trade and sees thousands of tons of the material.
Look at these guys.
Fake the Chinese drawing that's shopping a little bit.
Fairly harsh penalties for producers of tainted products.
But many consumers doubt that China's dinner tables can be completely free of
gutter oil.
I can do as accepted in our current society.
Everybody tries to swindle everybody else.
There's nothing we can do.
A mountain.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's a false gusting.
What that takes discussing
to whole new level.
I have never pouring it from the bucket.
And you hear that.
Go with get that soundbite.
No cause that to me I almost threw up.
I had to look away.
That's the first time I've ever had to look away on a show.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
Cause you knew where I was headed to someone's food.
Dude.
I almost threw up watching that.
So I did not have any of the street noodles.
I did have a lot of noodles though.
Oh my gosh.
Street noodles mother fucker.
Man.
But that you might've had some gutter oil.
Absolutely.
I absolutely might hot.
What the fuck man.
I would like to know if you had got her oil.
I probably got to assume when I see that when it said where it was and like I
probably had some gutter oil.
I would like to know how do you think we could find out when my friend was there
said it was like yeah I'm going to an eight it for a little while.
You know I got an a kick of eating it this way before the expos they came out
had a lot of diarrhea and it was a lot cause you're eating shit cause you're
eating someone else's shit.
That guy we boil it,
we put a flame under it is to me,
you know it's like when you,
when you see like the worst case scenarios about China and like then did you
ever see that HBO documentary about sitting them selling bay?
I think it was HBO.
They were selling children like oh like gosh guys were selling like their two
year old children.
This one boy was screaming cause his dad sold his brother away.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Deep Dark Shit.
And they were interviewing the guy who sold his kid and he was like,
look,
I didn't have any money.
I had a kid,
I had us all the kid.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's really fucked up.
I mean really fucked up.
But to me when I see stuff like that,
when I see that guy that was saying that,
you know people swindle people,
when you see the whole gutter oil thing,
it's like humanity.
If it,
she gets bad.
If people were in a basketball,
people go bad,
they go real bad.
They compartmentalize.
They don't like this.
I'm not concerned with who gets this.
Like they just don't think about it like I'm sure it's okay.
That lady was telling me I have bought a house.
You bought a house by feeding people shit.
How much shit did you have to shovel to get your house?
And you have to continue shoveling shit in order to pay for that house.
I assume they have mortgages over there.
Did they have any mortgages?
She's not buying a house with cash,
like showing up big fucking stack of paper.
Oh Dude,
that's insane.
Critic gross.
That's beyond gross.
I almost threw up on a podcast.
I've never done that before.
Like plopping sound to die hosted fear factor for.
I've seen some shit.
I'm not a regular person in that regard.
I seen more disgusting shit than almost any other person who's a comedian.
Yeah.
Up Close in person right there and help people get through eating and I got
nauseous from the smell the shit scooping it up.
That sound made it started scriptive yeah,
the I really,
I got that weird tingle in my throat.
I know controller.
Oh,
what is horrible.
Yeah.
Brian Kaplan told me he was in China and uh,
they were at a restaurant and the restaurant had pigs underneath the restaurant
and running around.
Yeah.
They were liking containers underneath the restaurant and they realized,
his mom asked and to realize that when you shit the shit was going down to where
the pigs were.
The pigs are eating your shit.
Human Shit.
Oh,
gross pigs,
mother fucker.
That's unfortunate.
Shia think,
I mean,
and they're doing it old school style.
You're shitting in a hole.
You're squatting like you were talking about in the first podcast before this
one where you talk about podcasts.
We did.
Yeah,
we did another podcast couple of,
couple of hours ago.
Um,
Ari was talking about how you'd go into these bathrooms and there's a hole in
the ground that's your toilet.
So underneath that whole pigs,
just
wait and see the browser.
So fucking great.
But again,
that's what happens when people just get,
when it goes bad,
play that noise again.
Jamie.
Don't do it.
Just play that noise alone.
That's that part.
Just queue it up in case we need all her,
all his cue it up because we did it.
Sounds like I need it.
Plop,
plop,
plop.